[Música]
i
usualmente en este espacio los días
viernes france24 les presenta el
programa kobe 19 la semana en américa un
programa que ya llegó a su fin la semana
pasada poniendo así punto final a dos
años de trabajo informando los a ustedes
todos los viernes sobre el acontecer de
la pandemia kobe 19 en su lugar y
también debido a la coyuntura política
que hay en nuestra región hoy vamos a
tener esta edición especial del debate
con motivo de las elecciones
presidenciales en colombia la segunda
vuelta de elecciones presidenciales en
este país y por qué pues porque sube la
atención y la expectativa en este país
suramericano este país está por vivir
como les digo la segunda vuelta
electoral en donde se espera que los
ciudadanos elijan al nuevo presidente
que llevará las riendas de esta nación
por los próximos cuatro años un país que
como ustedes saben tiene un escenario
político y social muy particular muy
distinto a muchas características que
tienen otros países de suramérica por
ejemplo y por eso allí las elecciones
presidenciales pues tampoco tendrían que
ser de otra manera también tiene sus
particularidades y queda muy claro que
gane quien gane
significará una nueva etapa en la era
política de colombia y por qué porque
los colombianos deberán elegir entre
gustavo petro que podría ser el primer
presidente de izquierda en la historia
de colombia veamos algunos datos gustavo
petro encabeza una coalición de partidos
de izquierda fue miembro de la cámara de
representantes también fue representante
a la cámara por la ciudad de bogotá
también fue senador de la república
candidato presidencial en 2010 2018 y
ahora en el 2022 también fue alcalde de
la ciudad de bogotá la capital de este
país suramericano es el segundo cargo
político más importante en colombia
es un político tradicional
gustavo petro es controvertido no ha
escapado al escándalo pero está decidido
a llegar a la casa de nariño veamos
entonces algunos de sus puntos generales
de sus líneas de propuestas está por
ejemplo en el papel en su propuesta
hacer una reforma agraria para aumentar
la producción agropecuaria también un
mayor cuidado del territorio es decir
que las explotaciones como por ejemplo
el fracking quedarían eliminadas e
intentaría darle un poco más de cuidado
a la biodiversidad del territorio
colombiano a que haciendo un poco un
guiño a la materia medioambiental
también abogaría por la igualdad para
las mujeres y para las poblaciones más
vulnerables y haría un desmonte del
esmad que es la policía antidisturbios
colombiana apoya el fin del servicio
militar obligatorio y propone la
prevalencia de las autoridades civiles
sobre los militares también la
implementación del acuerdo de paz
firmado durante la administración del
presidente santos y fomentar la
educación superior pública y gratuita
sólo por darles algunas líneas de lo que
propone este candidato
en el otro lado está rodolfo hernández
que no representa a un político
tradicional por lo menos en la esfera
colombiana no hace parte de los partidos
o de las coaliciones históricas de este
país su forma de expresarse la forma
como se dirige a los medios de
comunicación rompe con esa formalidad
que han mantenido los jefes de estado
colombianos hernández no tiene una
amplia experiencia en términos políticos
si lo comparamos y lo comparamos con
gustavo petro pero si ha demostrado
tener capacidad para ejecución y para
administrar como ingeniero él es
ingeniero de formación se dedicó a
proyectos de construcción de vivienda de
interés social por cerca de dos décadas
posteriormente saltó a la arena política
y fue elegido alcalde de la ciudad de
bucaramanga que es la capital del
departamento de santander es una dentro
de las cinco o seis ciudades más
importantes son más grandes en tamaño en
ese país ahora en el 2022 aspira a
llegar a la casa de nariño sin respaldo
político y abanderado de la lucha contra
la corrupción dentro de sus propuestas
veamos algunos puntos claves solamente
por mencionar algunos y acabar con la
corrupción que como les digo es su
bandera clave y su principal motivo de
campaña modificar las cárceles reducción
del estado colombiano fomentar la
educación a través de los créditos
reducir el iva al 10 por ciento e
impulsar un programa nacional de
vivienda rural
esta campaña no ha estado alejada de la
polémica el episodio más reciente fue
esta disputa realizada por autoridades y
también por los candidatos en torno a la
necesidad de realizar un debate
presidencial donde los ciudadanos
pudieran enterarse de las propuestas y
un poco controvertido las opiniones que
tienen estos candidatos en torno a
puntos claves de la coyuntura colombiana
entonces pues ahí es donde quedan
algunas preguntas al no poder realizar
este debate esto va en contra de los
votantes que tanto afectan entonces a
los candidatos pero la campaña también
estuvo plagada de acciones muy sucias
escándalos que dejan en entredicho la
altura de estos comicios unos comicios
que tampoco tienen grandes planes de
acción hay propuestas pero no han dicho
cómo las van a realizar y que tienen a
favor y eso sí no importa gane quien
gane allí en colombia está garantizado
que este país va a tener a una
vicepresidenta o por lo menos la primera
vicepresidenta afrodescendiente en la
historia de ese país es todo un orgullo
y un ejemplo de la diversidad colombiana
no me extiendo más en la introducción
para dar paso entonces a los invitados
porque muchos temas para hablar para
conversar antes de estas elecciones
presidenciales hemos convocado invitado
para este programa patricia muñoz y ella
es directora de posgrados en ciencia
política de la facultad de ciencia
política y relaciones internacionales de
la pontificia universidad javeriana en
la ciudad de bogotá también se une a
esta conversación desde la ciudad de
pereira en el corazón de la zona
cafetera colombiana está andrés segura
el des consultor en asuntos públicos
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
hacen parte de esta conversación estamos
a través de las diferentes redes
sociales estamos en facebook en
instagram en twitter ustedes ya lo saben
también pueden ver nuestra señal en
streaming a través de youtube no se
encuentran como france24
s arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 para que dejen
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas en
torno a este tema paso entonces a darle
la bienvenida a patricia en la ciudad de
bogotá patricia gracias por acompañarnos
nuevamente aquí en el debate de france
24 y faltando ya pocos días para estas
esta segunda vuelta presidencial en
colombia
impresiones generales como punto de
partida del análisis el balance que
usted hace de esta campaña de estos dos
candidatos que se juegan la silla
presidencial en la casa de nariño
muchas gracias santiago gracias por la
invitación un placer estar con ustedes
en efecto a un par de días de votar en
estas importantes elecciones el primer
balance que podemos hacer es a esa
sensación primero de incertidumbre y
algo de tensión que rodea el proceso
electoral
incertidumbre porque los estudios de
opinión nos han mostrado una diferencia
muy estrecha entre uno y otro candidato
saldos pedagógicos y temas que el país
deberá analizar y lo que bien usted
comentaba de las
estrategias utilizadas en la campaña y
cuáles son los límites de aquello de él
no todo vale no el fin justifica los
medios y las campañas deberían guardar
unos parámetros éticos que en aras de la
defensa de la democracia y por supuesto
lo que viene a partir del lunes con el
nuevo presidente con estas propuestas
que tendrán que profundizar en el cómo
la conformación del equipo de gobierno y
con las expectativas de los ciudadanos
que se elevan enormemente en época
electoral las campañas se encargan de
elevar ese nivel de expectativas pero
luego va a entrar a gobernar a alguien
que debe establecer un punto de
encuentro de alianzas y un punto de
acuerdo nacional para evitar que esas
esas distancias que se construyeron
durante la campaña le impidan construir
gobernabilidad
la opinión de patricia nuestra primera
invitada ahora le doy la bienvenida a
andrés en la ciudad de pereira en el
centro de colombia la zona cafetera
andrés gracias por acompañarnos hoy en
el programa punto de partida su opinión
general sobre estos comicios estas
campañas
todas estas coyunturas y escándalos que
ha habido en torno a los candidatos a la
forma de proceder de sus campañas y cómo
llega el país a estos dos candidatos
santiago un saludo un saludo a patricia
a toda la audiencia muchas gracias por
la invitación y estamos estamos viendo
un panorama muy de mucha incertidumbre
como dice patricia pero sobre todo de
saturación política lo que ha venido
pasando es el resultado de dos fenómenos
dos momentos de saturación uno
estructural que se basa en un
desconcierto y un aburrimiento de la
clase de los ciudadanos sobre la clase
política y sobre el establecimiento un
fenómeno mundial que se ha visto en
diferentes escenarios en latinoamérica e
incluso en otras regiones y que está
claramente estudiado en documentos como
los que salta el anterior o barómetro
del observatorio la democracia los de la
universidad de vanderbilt
hablando de la desconfianza que tiene
sobre la institucionalidad sobre los
mecanismos democráticos y al final
después de un proceso muy grande de
colombia de salir del tema del conflicto
como se como el eje de la discusión
política aterriza y explota en un
momento nuevas elecciones en donde los
dos candidatos
de otra manera y en momentos diferentes
representan el cambio en este momento
ahí este es un primer ejemplo de
saturación y cansancio de la ciudadanía
el segundo es que ha sido una campaña
muy larga se ha venido desde las las
llamadas primarias para toda la víscera
tino americana que se irán de los
partidos las discusiones iban desde
diciembre ya hemos venido marzo han sido
seis meses gustavo petro ha estado una
campaña muy larga para un candidato y
donde que ha hecho que su nombre sea el
eje de la conversación y rodolfo
hernández de alguna manera recoge al
final ese cansancio de la ciudadanía
frente a los otros candidatos pero al
día de hoy después de más de seis meses
donde en las elecciones han ocupado
buena parte de la agenda ya mucha gente
quiere que se acabe y sobre todo para
finalizar lo que ustedes viendo hablaba
de las campañas negativas los mensajes
los mensajes de ataque entre los
candidatos las polémicas es ha generado
han generado un mayor sentimiento de
aburrimiento y vamos a ver si eso va a
tener un resultado en las urnas del
domingo
bueno muchos puntos andrés voy a hacer
la ronda la inversa patricia le doy la
palabra andrés usted menciona cambio
porque hay necesidad o un deseo de la
sociedad colombiana de un cambio que
efectivamente va a tener lugar a partir
del domingo porque los dos candidatos
como lo decía en la introducción
representan escenarios políticos a los
que colombiano se ha enfrentado
en el pasado un candidato de la
izquierda y un candidato que no
pertenece a los grandes partidos y que
no tiene una tradición política y no
pertenece a las familias que han
gobernado ese país a lo largo de los
años el cambio sea como sea se va a
evidenciar a partir del 7 de agosto
cuando asuma nuevo presidente pero
porque es necesario ese cambio en ese
país
llevamos muchísimos años décadas en los
cuales venimos con las mismas
estructuras en el poder en colombia
estamos viendo que a través de
diferentes
modificaciones o ajustes es este se han
hecho las mismas estructuras que venían
durante mucho tiempo son las que han
venido ganando los espacios bajo las
mismas maneras de hacer política y
generando esa sensación de que la
política está sirviendo a las personas
es de alguna manera un resultado de que
el modelo liberal no ha logrado dar las
respuestas necesarias a la ciudadanía y
eso ha aterrizado en que la gente no
quiere más y cuando salimos del tema del
conflicto pues que se destaparon muchas
muchas otras preocupaciones
entre los ciudadanos y esto lo que
reflejan estos dos candidatos como decía
cada uno en su manera gustavo dentro
desde lo que se puede llamar la
izquierda y que no ha tenido un papel
protagónico en la política en
el cargo en el poder en el máximo cargo
de poder en colombia pero que cada
durante cada año ha venido creciendo
hasta un completo
desconocido en los temas de vida a nivel
nacional si conocen lo local y que
utiliza prácticas mentalmente anti
establecimiento en algunos casos se
pueden llamar te valoras pero que está
que está rompiendo a las formas sobre
todo el cómo se hace política en este
momento en elecciones eso de las formas
comienza a tener una importancia muy
grande para los ciudadanos patricia a su
punto de vista aquí es un cambio de
estructura un cambio de los personajes
un cambio del escenario un cambio del
modelo
gracias santiago un saludo caluroso
andrés qué gusto compartir este
escenario con andrés
lo expresaba bien andréis la bandera del
cambio se convirtió en los motores que
permitieron que dos candidatos anti
gobierno pasarán a la segunda vuelta los
altos niveles de insatisfacción con la
gestión del gobierno las necesidades que
se fue que fueron llevadas incluso a la
calle a través de la protesta social
demostraron la necesidad de romper con
estos viejos esquemas y formas de hacer
política y de afrontar unas viejas
problemáticas que aún se encuentran sin
resolver yo creo que esa o una al menos
de esas problemáticas muy sentidas por
los colombianos como lo muestran los
estudios de opinión pública es ese
sentimiento de que la corrupción se ha
instalado en beneficios de una clase
privilegiada en beneficio de las
personas
no del colectivo y ello viene saturando
y descansando agotando a los colombianos
y los dos candidatos que pasan a la
segunda vuelta se comprometen a
enfrentar este gran problema pero a la
parte de luchar contra la corrupción hay
una serie de cambios que la sociedad
viene reclamando desde diferentes
sectores y desde diferentes momentos el
desarrollo del agro del campo y la
implementación del proceso de paz el
poner límite fin a
esta lucha contra actores
ilegales contra la presencia de
economías ilícitas el dolor que genera
la muerte de los líderes sociales y de
los desmovilizados todo ello como señal
de protesta demandan un cambio en la
forma de hacer política y en la forma de
solucionar los problemas patricia andrés
ya lo mencionaba yo sea como sea gane
quien gane va a haber un cambio en la
forma de hacer la política en este país
sudamericano a raíz de esta elección
puede ser la consagración del sueño de
la izquierda colombiana que tantas
batallas ha dado a nivel político y
también desde la insurgencia a lo largo
de la historia colombiana patricia desde
su perspectiva de su opinión es la
oportunidad de la izquierda colombiana
de llegar al poder y por fin
desmitificar
eso que reina entre los colombianos de
cómo podría ser un gobierno de izquierda
cuando se tiene pues el ejemplo de cuba
al ejemplo de venezuela y simplemente la
vuelta de la esquina pero también hay
otros países como por ejemplo uruguay
en donde se ve un tipo de izquierda un
poco más moderada colombia le dará la
oportunidad la izquierda en esto en esta
ocasión
existe una importante posibilidad de que
así sea santiago y será la oportunidad
para que la izquierda no solo demuestre
esa capacidad de gobierno esa
experiencia acumulada en el ejercicio de
campañas pero también en el ejercicio de
otra forma de representación desde el
gobierno local y es la oportunidad para
que esta izquierda democrática después
de la firma de un acuerdo de paz logre
reducir estos niveles de temor de miedo
que se genera en buena parte de la
ciudadanía por la larga existencia del
conflicto armado y por la asociación que
muchos ciudadanos han realizado de esta
izquierda democrática con la izquierda
levantada en armas es una gran
oportunidad en este sentido y creo que
la izquierda ha trabajado intensamente
para poder lograr el poder en esta
ocasión andrés opinión sobre este tema
sobre las que la colombiana y esta
oportunidad creo que nunca en la
historia de este país ha estado tan
cerca de lograr llegar a la casa de
nariño y tomar las riendas en el poder
en este país
si es interesante la izquierda como se
como heredera de unas visiones o unos
partidos de tintes socialistas en los en
hace décadas en la primera vez que tiene
la oportunidad pero no hay que dejar ver
que no hay que olvidar que colombia ha
tenido
gobiernos que se podrían llamar al día
de hoy socialdemócratas en que durante
el siglo 20 sin ningún problema el punto
es esa reflexión de cómo la izquierda
estuvo para el ciudadano del común
relacionada con el conflicto armado y
con la insurgencia y que eso ha tenido
consecuencias clave en su perspectiva y
esta es la oportunidad de demostrar para
estar para demostrar que si son una
opción para hacerlo pero el problema es
el rechazo que tiene el líder en este
momento el vencido ya política y no
solamente por su pasado insurgente sino
el carácter y del de cárter y su perfil
confrontacional en todos momentos o sus
escenarios políticos ha generado
demasiados enemigos y en su talante las
escenas del gobierno lo ha confirmado
que genera mucho miedo entre las
personas y la oportunidad de demostrar
que el gobierno puede
dt desde el gobierno pueden implementar
un gobierno izquierda que sea
legítimo y sobre todo viable hacia el
futuro para el país está en la capacidad
de esta persona de moldear ajustar
moderar sus actitudes sus
características su criterio para
habilitar un espacio a una conversación
y no quedarse en posturas que podrían
ser vistas como radicales y unas
posiciones confrontacionales que serían
muy difíciles y tendrían que variantes
desperdiciaría esa oportunidad hasta el
momento el grupo que está logrando
consolidar da muestras de que pueden
lograr hacerlo pero bomberos es pero
genera miedos muchos comentarios que
hacen al momento y te hacen que
incluso puede hacer que pierda las
elecciones estoy con patricia que tiene
unas altas posiciones de presidente pero
es un candidato que ha estado liderando
durante mucho tiempo la intención de
otro en el país y precisamente al final
es donde se ha destacado el rechazo
hacia el consolidado que al final es una
es un síntoma
de la democracia con una campaña muy
fuerte no lo ha podido cerrar como él
quería andrés pero a pesar del rechazo y
de estas discrepancias que puede generar
al interior de la sociedad colombiana ha
logrado gustavo petro consolidar se ha
logrado consolidar una imagen como un
político
firme como un político que ha logrado
desempeñarse en diferentes
cargos a nivel público cuál fue la clave
del para consolidarse cómo logró
cautivar a esos pocos o muchos como
usted lo quiera llamar que los siguen y
que respaldan ese proyecto de una
izquierda colombiana
creo que lo acomodarse en la disyuntiva
y el antagonismo que se generó alrededor
de álvaro uribe en los últimos 20 años
hay que tener claro que para colombia el
líder político más importante en las
últimas décadas y nos y acá es
importancia no estoy hablando si a favor
o en contra es álvaro uribe y aquí como
en toda latinoamérica hubo uno o un par
de líderes populares caudillistas en
colombia el representante fue álvaro
uribe gustavo petro los últimos 12 años
se consolidó como la recogió el hito el
la contraposición el antagonista de
álvaro uribe el refugio esa idea y ahí
fue catapultando y en este momento fue
creciendo a punta de polémicas a generar
de profundizar la división en el país a
generarlo a profundizar los temas que
generaban polarización en los temas él
logra consolidar ese espacio y encuentro
un escenario muy fértil y es el gobierno
iván duque que tienen una muy mala
percepción en el país una mala
aceptación de sus políticas por parte de
los colombianos y colombianas
resalte en este momento mucho más fuerte
ya es una campaña muy buena en el
sentido que refugio muy buena parte de
la votación de 2018 vamos ya llegando a
la mitad del programa avanzó con otros
temas pasó entonces a hablar del otro
candidato que rodolfo hernández ya lo
mencionaba yo un candidato que no va con
maquinarias políticas no hace parte de
los partidos tradicionales o de las
coaliciones que se han conformado para
este tipo de elección de presidencial un
candidato que se sale de todos los
estereotipos de un mandatario de lo que
puede ser un candidato o un posible
mandatario en colombia en patricia su
opinión sobre este candidato y ese
ascenso que tuvo sorpresivo para esa
primera vuelta que hoy lo tiene en en
esta segunda vuelta presidencial y con
también con muchas posibilidades de
llegar a la casa de nariño y darle un
giro completamente a la política
colombiana diría yo que incluso hasta
descentralizar el gobierno porque
prácticamente piensa gobernar desde
piedecuesta santander o bucaramanga en
vez de bogotá
así es santiago un ascenso vertiginoso
debo decir que nos sorprendió a muchos
que veníamos haciéndole seguimiento a su
campaña una campaña muy efectiva en
términos de sintonizarse con un grupo de
población a partir primero de apoderarse
de la de la bandera de la lucha contra
la corrupción esta bandera que
tradicionalmente la habían defendido
líderes políticos del centro fue tomada
por rodolfo hernández y a fuerza de
repetir terminó apropiándose
de esta lucha contra la corrupción
frases sencillas directas efectivas como
parte de la estrategia de campaña
electoral y el uso de las redes sociales
que le permitió la posibilidad de
difundir mensajes sin necesidad de
entrar en procesos de confrontación el
vídeo corto y la explicación de su
programa de gobierno a través de vídeos
el vídeo sencillo que se comunicó 4
detecto la posibilidad de hacer una
difusión amplia y masificar a través de
las redes sus mensajes a través del uso
de esta estrategia le fue supremamente
útil esto le permitió que frases
sencillas a lara sin necesidad de
presentar grandes propuestas en formas
como iba a adelantar sus a su lucha
contra la corrupción frase es muy
sencilla aún no tienen en esta segunda
vuelta si andrés algo para añadir en
torno al candidato rodolfo hernández una
campaña particular porque por primera
vez tal vez este me pueda corregir la
campaña no giró en torno a la lucha
contra las guerrillas colombianas no
giró en torno a la lucha contra el
narcotráfico sino que giró en torno a la
corrupción esta es una campaña que tocó
este tema como bandera que no ningún
candidato lo había tomado como su
bandera principal de campaña
llega y la utiliza como bandera y la
exprime de una forma exagerada de una
forma demagógica es tal como lo describe
patricia sintetizar los mensajes de una
forma y llevó la discusión solamente a
ese tema que lo hacía muy atractivo
siendo una preocupación de las personas
de los ciudadanos
una preocupación claramente vista en
cualquiera de los estudios pero al mismo
tiempo que se alineaba directamente con
el malestar el rechazo e incluso la guía
que puedan tener las personas frente al
establecimiento porque no hay muchas
oportunidades y en ese caso en un
discurso en una persona totalmente
desconocida logra en una ola que para
que el término respondiendo a una
coyuntura particular
se dio su crecimiento y su alto
conocimiento en el momento que era que
fue lo hace un salto en las últimas tres
semanas antes de primeramente eso le
permitió llegar a la segunda vuelta y
hoy en día termina en un fracaso
en la lucha por quién puede representar
mejor el cambio y entonces estamos
hablando de una persona que
ideológicamente era el cambio como
gustavo vendrá una lucha permanente a
alguien que lo que estamos rompiendo son
todos los esquemas de la forma de hacer
política
y eso llama mucho la atención detalles
como dar discursos desde la cocina de su
casa y me dicen mucho de lo que puede
ser esta persona alrededor de cómo se
pueden hacer las cosas diferente y eso
es una forma de mostrar que si puede
hacer las cosas diferentes para salir de
las realidades que nos han llevado a la
corrupción va a agilizar un poco porque
te hace me va acabando el tiempo y tengo
muchos temas andrés pasó a preguntarle
usted para hacer la ronda la inversa
sobre componentes de estas campañas
muchos escándalos muchísima
desinformación a través de las redes
sociales también
los vídeos que dieron a conocer
donde supuestamente colaboradores de la
campaña de petró estaban haciendo alguna
estrategia para poder quitarse el camino
algunos candidatos o personajes que
ellos consideraban había que dejar de
lado para avanzar y ganar más votos
también los escándalos que han rodeado a
rodolfo hernández por un caso un
presunto caso de corrupción que lleva
arrastrando desde que era alcalde de
bucaramanga ha habido muchísima
desinformación en también en los medios
de comunicación y todo este escándalo de
un debate presidencial a sólo tres días
antes de la segunda vuelta electoral
esto solamente lo ve uno en un país como
colombia en donde hay un fallo y no lo
respetan en dónde sale este escándalo de
los videos en otro país el candidato
hubiera renunciado a la candidatura aquí
resulta que lo fortalece en cierta forma
son componentes que sólo se ven en ese
país
aquí lo que estamos viendo en en alguna
medida a su vez una campaña fanaticadas
en este caso es lo que representan más
que propiamente las propuestas por eso
hoy vamos a ver que las discusiones de
propuestas se irán más alrededor de
polémicas que una discusión profunda en
antes de la primera vuelta o discusiones
sobre el sistema pensional pero fue más
un cruce de declaraciones de gustavo
petro que digo una cosa y después el
equipo de programático dijo otra pero
pasa exactamente lo mismo con rodolfo
termina siendo la polémica y es cómo se
defienden en los unos a los otros en la
segunda vuelta
gustavo petro encuentran que no puede
tiene mucho margen de crecimiento es
decir de lograr su acumular más votos
mientras que rolfo tenía muchísimo
empieza una campaña negativa en la cual
a una gran parte de la ciudadanía que no
sabía general rodolfo le presentan a
rodolfo la versión de dentro y eso es lo
que empieza a limitar la forma de
crecimiento de terror fernández y es lo
que vamos a ver que no ninguno de los
dos candidatos está recogiendo los
fondos que hubiera podido esperar
además gustavo petro tuvo que aguantar
durante buena parte de la campaña ataque
sismo que era profundizar los miedos que
habían sobre él
para evitar su crecimiento y eso lo
hacían diferentes candidatos en primera
vuelta entonces al final en un trabajo
si uno se pone a mirar lo fácil y
facilista
pero ahí es sucedido y místicas patricia
y en este caso es lo mencionaba también
en la introducción hay muchas propuestas
hay muchas cosas para cambiar de de
fondo o aspectos que necesitan reformas
en colombia pero no hay propuestas
exactas de cómo lo van a hacer un país
que tiene un déficit fiscal complicado
la pobreza aumentó después del
confinamiento de la pandemia de kobe 19
los problemas económicos los vienen
arrastrando desde hace ya varios años y
ninguno de los dos candidatos dice cómo
van a ser todas estas promesas y pájaros
que venden en el aire a los ciudadanos
hay hay que decir a andrés que quizás
gustavo petro llegó un poco más allá en
explicarnos ese cómo y precisamente
algunas de sus propuestas se desataron
todo un debate alrededor de las mismas
lo cual es lo que se busca en una
campaña generar un debate público
alrededor de las propuestas a escuchar
las posiciones y tratar de votar por
esas posiciones
en ese sentido si debemos reconocer que
la campaña de rodolfo hernández quizás
fue mucho más limitada no sólo en torno
a las propuestas sino casi que en la
totalidad del cómo va a realizarlo
campañas que nos dejan ver el peso de
los factores emocionales esa
emocionalidad bien a favor del candidato
o bien en contra del otro candidato que
entonces tengo miedo me genera temor un
candidato y entonces adhiero al otro sea
1 o sea 2 aún con propuestas o sin
propuestas esto es parte del debate
público que nos queda ahora como una
necesidad como un salto pedagógico que
siempre debemos trabajar la necesidad de
exigir a los candidatos a mayor
profundidad en lo en sus planteamientos
y mayores claridad es frente a los
equipos y a la manera como van a
adelantar las propuestas y por supuesto
una ciudadanía que tiene que
involucrarse mucho más en la exigencia
los datos de estos puntos
exigir es el compromiso también parte de
la ciudadanía tiene que exigir y pedir
de sus gobernantes un mejor desempeño
factor importante y destacado para estas
elecciones son las candidatas a la
vicepresidencia
estamos hablando de dos mujeres dos
mujeres afrodescendientes ha llamado
mucho la atención en el escenario
internacional estas dos mujeres por el
perfil que tienen y lo que representan
para la sociedad colombiana y en el caso
de francia márquez pues el pasado que
tiene ella como una líder de una de las
zonas más afectadas por el conflicto a
lo largo de muchas décadas
como ven ustedes las figuras de las
vicepresidentas y puede ser esta
mancuerna ideal y apoyo para estos dos
futuros presidentes cualquiera de los
dos que gane patricia
es un paso más santiago a esta deuda con
la mujer en su en el escenario de
representación política dos mujeres
afrodescendientes de región esto es muy
importante una con una trayectoria de
liderazgo social como francia márquez y
la otra fórmula como una compañía desde
el campo de la educación su formación en
educación pero ambas provenientes de
región ambas conocedoras de unas
realidades que van a enriquecer muy
seguramente la toma de decisiones desde
el centro desde el presidente de la
república no es en el
la única respuesta que esperamos como
mujeres para ocupar estos espacios sino
en el último paso que se debe dar ya
avanzamos de manera importante en la
elección al congreso de la república
pero sigue habiendo una brecha
importante
en el modelo político que tiene que
seguir siendo trabajado me quedan un par
de minutos para hacer una de las últimas
preguntas andrés y es sobre los miedos
sigan a gustavo petro hay cierto miedo a
que haya un cambio en ese modelo
colombiano y el intente también hacer
modificaciones a la ley colombiana
intenté perpetuarse en el país eso es
donde los comentarios perpetuarse al
poder hay comentarios así entre los
colombianos que lo ven como una amenaza
teniendo como espejo lo que ha sucedido
en venezuela y en nicaragua por ser un
gobierno izquierda pero también está el
miedo por el lado de una posible
presidencia de rodolfo hernández de una
persona que desconoce ampliamente el
funcionamiento del estado y que pueda
incurrir en fallos o en equivocaciones
en sus formas de proceder precisamente
por desconocer cómo se hace la política
a nivel nacional
usted cree que está en riesgo la
democracia está en riesgo
el estado de derecho colombiano con
estos dos candidatos y con el escenario
político que llegue a este país
está en riesgo de debilitarse pero
tiendo a ser optimista al respecto con
los dos candidatos creo que hay en las
herramientas para hacerlo y creo que de
alguna manera los miedos que aunque
están sustentados la campaña los agenes
los ha vuelto mucho más grandes
empiezo por rodolfo rodolfo es una
persona que sus solucionador de
problemas es no tiene una visión de país
no la proyecta no representa eran
finales rhodes solver problemas en este
caso la incertidumbre que hay es quien
va a ser el equipo porque el equipo que
tenga va a ser supremamente poderoso en
comparación a otros gobiernos porque va
a tener un margen de maniobra muy grande
si es un buen equipo puede funcionar
bastante bien el punto es que tanto se
puede meter rol fue en estas decisiones
teniendo un carácter impulsivo y que
unai no hay una línea política de visión
de país al respecto con gustavo petro
enrique entonces su carácter autoritario
efectivamente ha tenido muestras en
diferentes escenarios de autoritarismo
incluso ha hecho comentarios un poco
difíciles alrededor de perpetuarse en el
poder directa o indirectamente para
repetir un par de veces te genera miedos
pero su acercamiento al establecimiento
en los últimos en los últimos meses le
pone limitantes al respecto entonces va
a ser una lucha entre su vocación
personal que lo tiende a llevarlo a
buscar manifestaciones sociales de apoyo
para generar presión versus los todos
los alianzas que atenten hacer para
mantener el poder esas tensiones creo
que van a controlar porque sus riesgos
que pueden existir para demostrar la
suerte está echada los colombianos están
convocados a las urnas para este domingo
votar y elegir al presidente que va a
llevar los destinos de este país por los
próximos cuatro años si tú alguna
representa un cambio en la política ya
lo hemos analizado a cada patricia de
andrés les agradezco mucho por haber
hecho este análisis para la audiencia de
américa latina' la audiencia de france
24 ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales siga con nosotros
[Música]